rien que moi ces comptages des traités
non je paie comptant j'ai prêté une de
mes voitures à benjamin week end une
nourriture de sport ça commence par l
j'avais dit par hbo voilà nîmes a dit
est-ce que je peux t'emprunter ta
voiture pour aller en week-end et est
bonne ça il me dit très bien je prends
ta voiture etc une petit point ta
voiture les défoncer faut que tu arrêtes
de la prêter à tes potes moi j'ai bien
avant d'occuper c'est super et c'est moi
qui prends la voiture il m'envoie une
photo fièrement sur l'autoroute en train
de rouler très vite les 15 minutes plus
tard il m'appelle la voiture défoncée
nom et pas dans l'émission il était venu
avec des avec des bandelettes si le
diable me suis fait je me suis fait mal
avec mon grip ingénierie et en fait il
avait en fait il ya il amène et j'essaie
de hockey mais il a neigé sur une jambe
et donc il y avait un peu donné sur le
bas côté et j'ai fait un coup à droite
un coup à gauche un coup à droite un
coup à gauche et avait peu de voitures
c'est vrai j'ai tapé et l'avant et
derrière et le côté droit
[Applaudissements]